It's something of an understatement to say
that Warner Bros.' slate of DC films have
trouble at the theaters.
Though fans have largely enjoyed the DC Comics
movies and each franchise entry has done relatively
well at the box office, critics have consistently
ripped the offerings to shreds.
With the exception of 2017's Wonder Woman,
the DC Extended Universe has really been struggling.
Marvel, on the other hand, routinely owns
the box office, captivates critics, and holds
the attention of theatergoers worldwide each
time it rolls out a new film.
As Avengers: Infinity War proves for the umpteenth
time, the MCU's cavalcade of superheroes has
a grip on Hollywood that doesn't show any
signs of slowing.
So, how does one patch up the problems of
the DC Universe, and potentially bring it
up to Marvel's speed?
Infinity War screenwriters Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely have a simple solution.
On a recent episode of Kevin Smith's "Fatman
on Batman" podcast, Smith asked the writers:
"If someone offered you a ton of money and
swayed you to the dark side and said, 'Fix
these movies,' how would you fix the DC Universe?"
Markus dished up his no-frills, all-fun filmmaking
game plan: Put the central lineup of DC heroes
on the shelf for a moment and focus on just
one character at a time rather than the universe
as a whole.
"Look at what Marvel did out of necessity,
in that they didn't have their A-list characters.
They didn't have Spider-Man.
They didn't have the X-Men."
Instead, the MCU's opening salvo was Iron
Man, a leading character that might not have
been the most obvious choice as the godfather
to the entire Marvel Universe, but eventually
worked out pretty well.
"He's pretty famous.
He's Iron Man.
But he wasn't there.
And they made a really good movie out of it."
As for how that applies to the DC Universe,
well, Markus thinks it's all about making
a few creative character choices there, too,
by giving Superman and Batman some time off,
and exploring other characters from the comics
that might have some similar appeal.
"Go through the vast world and go, 'That guy
or that girl,' and go, 'Let's just make a
really good movie."
For his part, McFeely also agreed that making
a single film at a time is the way to go.
"Strategically, 'Make one.
To quote Justice League, 'Save one person.'"
Perhaps they're on to something.
From the studio cooking up a slew of Joker
movies simultaneously, Ben Affleck's flip-flopping
about whether or not to ditch the Caped Crusader
cowl, and executives mapping out its alternate
universe movie banner on the side, things
are a bit of a mess down in the DC Universe.
"There's a lot of spaghetti being thrown at
the wall."
We can't say for certain whether Markus and
McFeely's proposition is the perfect one to
save the DC Universe, but slowing down to
stop the spaghetti from sliding off the walls
and onto the floor sounds like a smart idea.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!